hey I'm Butch Hartman creator of The
Fairly OddParents and Danny Phantom and
a bunch of other Nickelodeon shows hey
I'm Kira and today we are going to be
drawing oh you don't know no no what are
we doing so today we're gonna be drawing
SpongeBob means know what from memory
spongebob does not cross my Facebook
feed
yeah well you're gonna have a touch but
first be sure to stay tuned to the end
of the video to find out how you can
enter for a chance to win this Wacom
Intuos tablet
wacka-wacka welcome for all of your
digital drawing needs
Wacka Wacka Wacka m-- I know how to
dress for up characters but the memes I
again you know how to make sure there's
like a million of them I know you memes
I know I know I tried to do you know
what meme actually means it means Butch
Hartman can't draw this since the cut
means oh no I don't know which one that
one is is that the one where he's just
like he's just like open mouth uh-huh
all right handsome Squidward okay
okay this is the one I pretty sure I can
do what is I talked about it in an older
episode wait how can you explain this to
me he's a huge mush I know Squidward -
beautiful he's like what he wishes he
could be guy let me break it down for
you so he's like a cave and spongebob
he's got like a pace right okay a face a
face yes okay
he's got like a little loincloth blowing
clawing pie and he's like shocked
so he's like like that he's got like his
mouth kind of off to the side and he's
like okay I got it
maybe do I do you want me to stand here
the whole time and he looks like a man
more than a octa was squid for today a
day as we were chase sort of he's got
like she's like a man wearing a way to
word like body paint okay got it got it
okay okay very handsome
I think I got this he said not having it
at all one thing very distinct about
handsome Squidward he has
squinted closed eyes and very pursed
lips hmm like I like the like the
smolder
yes have you actually seen this man
before aye I think I know what it is
right
I've seen it before and I don't really
pay attention to means so this is a
universal mean I would say that is so
it's a smaller nose yeah same nose but
smaller same nose but smaller he's
handsome Squidward
how many fingers did spongebob that
again or okay he's a four fingered
cartoon
I wonder why spongebob is the thing that
gets me methide so much I mean they're
very funny drawings but it's like so
much so many episodes right yeah there's
like so much to pull from it is a lot to
draw on I guess what is he what is he
looking at when he's doing this he's
kind of just like staring off into the
void into the boy Jason I am here for
you for whatever you need I will be your
meme spirit guide I don't know how big
his eyes are yeah when you're drawing
people surprise they're either have
really big eyes or really small eyes I'm
like a Luke like it doesn't quite look
like what I'm imagining you know what
kids someone ever tells you memes are
easy
you tell him well Jackie said they're
not names are hard memes are really hard
actually no I think I do something I do
like a surfing hi spongebob
write something hi wonderful you know
what actually looking at mine I think
that is kind of what he is which well
you're at Nickelodeon did you get to
meet or hang out with any of the
spongebob crew absolutely I met them of
course and then worked around them every
day with the environment in those days
was very interesting because we all knew
each other we saw each other but
everybody was so focused on making their
shows all day we were kind of just in
our little nest doing our work but
occasionally they have you know they
have office parties and get-togethers
and events and things we'd see each
other they were the nicest guys you know
Vince Waller is a very good friend of
mine very sweet guy and super talented
artist Steve Hillenburg I knew him
pretty good didn't know him as well as I
wanted to he was a very quiet guy but
the nicest guy in the world knew him for
like we have about 20 years mine's going
good so far
I made the mouth a little bigger because
you made me really I'm going huge with
the mouth I just I feel like I feel like
that's the whole mean it's just like
it's just
yeah he's very surprised I may have
screwed up his feet how could you do
that I think I may have given him more
feet than he actually has what does that
mean what how did you do that what does
that mean no no no no no does he have
like our kid here
yes no I don't know yeah you should give
it like I love these details you're
adding though and I think you should go
for it does he have like pimples well no
because he's already got holes Oh true
true I'm not deleting that some ships
have sailed already it's wrong
let me ask you this have you watched my
youtube channel I have not I need to
what is it it has a super creative name
are you ready yes
it's called Butch Hartman fantastic well
I do a lot of stuff about artwork and
cartoons it's entertainment based like
you know if a new Marvel movie comes out
I'll draw like Marvel characters in The
Fairly OddParents style I did a bunch of
Danny Phantom ten years later videos
with Danny Phantom is very popular
character that's awesome people love
seeing artists you know really explain
their process and communicate with
people
I actually really like when I'm drawing
that's what's important this could be
the birth of a new spongebob meme that
would be dope how many choices you have
I am like three did he have like hair on
the top of his feet you know I like some
yeah I'm here on the top of his feet I
don't think he does but I think he
looked cute with hair on his feet it's
funny I now when I think of Patrick I
see your drawing in my head this is like
extra super challenging though because
not only do you have to draw this
character you have to draw him in a very
specific pose yeah how you doing Kevin
I'm almost done you're almost done how
are you doing I'm doing pretty good I'm
like just I'm nitpicking now sorry
anyway he's adding some shading in here
now quite sure I know that this from
wrong too but oh well he does look like
he's like tripping balls
yeah okay good you know what I think
you'll capture the spirit of him yeah
nothing else all right you good I am
done all right
let's stop that all set yeah I think we
did all right I mean the expression
isn't like exactly right Jason how do
you think you did you know I think I
followed directions I did not get a face
yeah because I was trying to draw
spongebob first so maybe this is
actually a test on my teaching abilities
and explain well I do something that
looks like a Squidward type of character
could be related to him I want to see
what she thinks
she's the judge so I leave it up to you
be the judge of mine all right how you
think you did I have no idea I feel like
I'm remembering something different but
you know I think it's funny maybe this
can be the new meme I think I did okay I
think it's surprising that I remember
this meme better than you do I think
it's surprising as well yeah all right
let's do it
let's switcheroo ah I understand the
excess of feet now right very nice okay
this is really good okay I like that now
I think I have seen this yes oh my god
spongebob meets Homer Simpson oh man I
think less than an excess of feet it
feels like you gave him shoes I gave him
the wrong feet you gave him in wrong
feet you didn't give him too many his
feet are just numb they're just nubs
he's a starfish you don't got fear his
lips
they're perfect I love it he kind of
looks like an actor but I can't really
place her so you gave him walleyes yeah
I don't know
I thought the walleyes felt right yeah
my brain and you also gave him small
eyes yeah you gave him small eyes and
walleyes walleye small eyes am i right
ladies
yep no dad once again Butch Hartman
reality hit switch Hartman in the face
oh I did oh well okay was the neck up
there you got it close yours is like
really close much you know this looks
like in the twilight zone years ago the
show to serve man looks like the alien
from deserve man no no no that's what
that is
oh boy Oh
Wow Wow
the only thing easy to do is the cheaper
like oh no oh yeah he's got like tusks
teeth this is spot on friend what about
Jason I think you did better than I did
yeah I think I think I think if we
combined our drawings they would be
perfect right mouth is not not as big
not as big I I led you astray Jeff you
led me astray after all the help I gave
you with the other episodes I just the
thing that I remember most about the
meme is that his mouth is a gaping huge
it is it is huge you know what I did
like I did add the thing the is that the
overlook the little dangly
of dangly Wayne in the back of the mouth
wow it's the best Patrick you've drawn
thank you you've only drawn two and this
one takes the cake
thank you this is also an excellent
Patrick once again not super accurate
but very Jackie okay giveaway time if
you want to enter for a chance to win
this Wacom Intuos tablet all you have to
do is go to the BuzzFeed comics
Instagram that's at comics on Instagram
and find this post and follow the
instructions in the description best of
luck to you digital painting photo
editing comic and manga you don't have
to be accurate with everything in life
that's literally what we're doing on the
show if you throw a potato at someone
and you miss their head but you hit
their chest it's still gonna really hurt
them so where do you get these metaphors
[Music]